i always contend that well our job is so
much harder than musicians
because
because a music person will be on the
road and you're pissed off if they don't
play their hits
and then uh the comedians will be on the
road and they're pissed off if they hear
the same joke you know heard that
it's insane they i mean can you imagine
just playing one hit you get you get one
hit
and you can just tour for the rest of
your life well not only that i talk
about the fact of even the writing even
the writing is so different what you can
get away with as a
music writer
as opposed to a comedy writer like i
talk about how even the beatles you know
wrote hey jude one of the best songs but
a big part of it and it was written down
was
that can't really be part of a routine
try it you should try it
two guys walk into a bar and then
nah nah nah nah you know what happened
for a long time
for a long time
so when you travel you take your wife uh
when she's healthy and your daughter
when they they come out some like we uh
we have a once we kind of started doing
theaters so we got tour bus and uh
so they will come out with me on some of
some of them some of them you know they
always tend to choose my wife we just
went to vegas my wife did uh came to
vegas
so she doesn't come to you know all the
city she's cities
right same as mine they want the good
shopping and restaurants yes which are
few and far between because most of the
gigs are in between
a good place and another good place
do you have a nightmare story about uh
doing stand-up what's the worst gig
or weirdest gig that you ever um
you know i mean one i talked about in my
special i did a corporate gig and the
whole audience didn't speak english
[Laughter]
and do you find that a barrier yeah yeah
yeah that was
you know when we first started i was in
new york you would do shows that yeah
it's broadway comedy club it was the
improv but it wasn't the improv that was
the other you know the original yeah
but it was uh we remember we'd do shows
and there would be sometimes you'd be on
stage and you're not really like getting
laughs and you you know after you've
been coming for a while you're like i
know these jokes are funny like i do the
same jokes every night like i know they
should be working right and then you
then look at the audience and you're
like where's everybody from it's like a
whole group from uh china or something
that's like an asian yeah none of them
speak english but they just want the
experience of a comedy club
they're like you're like does anybody
speak english they're like no and you're
like okay
well i had that i had that same thing
with i was uh when i was starting out my
career i was diana ross's opening act
and uh the room got sold out at caesar's
palace and the room got sold out to i
think it was sony japan or whatever it
was the full room there wasn't one
american in the room and i was the
opening act and it was
hellish but you know what silence is
golden i know they say that but it
wasn't it wasn't really golden for me
until i went late
did i don't do that much anymore like
that that was a big thing right where
you would open for music acts
yeah
yeah it was big for me that was kind of
exciting um i had no act per se and i
did uh
do you remember the merv griffin show
yeah i did the mer griffin show and uh i
got a call from gene simmons of kiss at
their height
you know and i thought oh my god he goes
i watched you on on merv griffin and i'd
like you to open up for my girlfriend
and i go oh okay who's your girlfriend
and at that time he was living with
diana ross and that was his girlfriend
he hired me and every night the audience
hated me they didn't want to see me they
didn't come there to see
i was unknown
i was an idiot um the lights would go
down the crowd would roar they go ladies
and gentlemen caesar's palace is proud
to present an evening of diana ross and
there'd be like this wall of sound and
if you listened really closely or you
were my mom you could hear but first
enjoy howie mandel and i would just walk
out to just
disappointment a room of disappointment
but you learn it makes you stronger you
don't use that muscle it goes away
that makes you so much stronger like
dealing with uh that science that's what
i always thought with new york while we
were so
why i liked a lot of comics in new york
and i think new york produces a lot of
great comics is because you're
performing regularly in front of four to
six people you know that's my favorite
thing i still do that now so i've been
writing
uh trying to prepare for a set that i
got to do
later on in in a couple of months and
this is my first time out and i what i
do is i'm just finding places where i'm
comfortable to be which is a lot more i
put up a lot more walls than than most
people so the other night i performed
there was a little tiny room there's you
know uh flappers comedy club here in
town but they have it's called the yuhu
room
and it was a little room i said i want
to do two sets in one night at least and
not leave the building so there were
seven people sitting in this yoo room
which at capacity probably holds 40 but
it wasn't capacity it was like six
but to me those are my favorite moments
because if i can get even a smile in
that room i know that it works
it becomes so much easier when you get
in front of a big room yeah it's
probably not even good it's just
i mean they're close too it feels like
you're like in the room y'all in the
studio you're in like you're you're all
just next to each other you're barely on
a stage you're barely above them so
there's no well not only that i i did my
first uh
bit and the woman sitting there goes
i don't get it
i go well thank you i don't usually get
that kind of feedback from an audience
like it just could go over somebody's
head but usually silently but then i
spent the next 10 minutes explaining
and she went oh
that's funny so i knew
but so i knew it was
like i never did that again but it was
it is uh you've played that room
i played that room yeah i remember wait
so there's a room in new york called the
village lantern it was kind of by the
comedy cellar kind of right you know
mcdougall
area and uh we that we had they had a
room like that and so when you would
start shows when you're first starting
you would just say we'd get two you
basically would trick two people to go
down there and sit or four
and then you'd be like all right
someone's got to go on stage so these
people don't leave and let's try to get
more people down there you're just
trying to create a show right well
sometimes i would go on and one time
there's these two couples sitting in the
furrows so i go up and i'm just you know
i have just this energy the whole time
and so it's i'm just sitting there
trying to talk to him and then the two
girls just stand up and take a picture
with me i mean
like you know no one knows me it's not
like they're doing it because i'm famous
they're doing it just like
out of hook
this is good for my instagram
yeah
they they just sit there and they just
look and took a picture and they sat
back down and i mean no one really
talked about it no one you know
bathroom if you had to go
people would have to walk behind you on
stage to go to the bathroom i had that
when i started out there was a club in
montreal on on crescent street before
there was even a yuck yucks there i
started at a club named yucky in toronto
and they had the bathroom behind so when
i would you know and i'd get scared i
didn't know that at the beginning so i'd
be doing my act and then somebody would
start walking toward me and toward me
and now they're stepping on the stage
and i'd go [ __ ] where is going and then
he'd walk past me
and then they told me i didn't know the
bathroom was behind me and then i'd be
doing it and then right on the punch
line you could hear the flush
you know but we as as comedians have
worked in
like weird only comedians get
asked to
be in these predicaments that are just
unbelievable but they give us great
stories don't they
[Music]
you